de voir à l'écran ah il est là
bonjour Stéphane en fait ah bah toi tu
as de la chance d'avoir le thé et le
confort dans ton bureau je suis désolé
pour les sénateurs et sénatrices et nos
invités nous n'aurons pas de thé à
disposition pendant la réunion il s'est
réservé uniquement aux présidents de la
délégation aux outre-mer
très tôt ce matin
je disais on attend que Stéphane soit
connecté mais non il était déjà connecté
bon ben écoutez on va pouvoir démarrer
si tu le permets Stéphane et donc chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs je suis
très heureuse ce matin d'inauguré avec
mon collègue et président donc Stéphane
Artano la première réunion commune à nos
deux délégations la délégation au droit
des maires et aux outre-mer sur la
parentalité dans les outre-mer au cours
des prochains mois nos deux délégations
vont en effet mener ensemble un travail
sur cette thématique et faire converger
leurs approches dans le but de produire
un rapport commun je me félicite de
cette collaboration entre nos deux je
suis convaincue que croiser nos regards
et nos analyses constituera une grande
richesse pour nous tous la thématique de
la parentalité dans les outre-mer nous
permettra d'aborder de nombreux sujets
les spécificités structures familiales
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
l'importance des familles monoparentales
au sein desquelles vivent plus de la
moitié des mineurs aux Antilles contre
20% en France métropolitaine la
répartition des rôles parentaux
également les politiques familiales et
sociales les dispositifs de soutien à la
parentalité et j'en passe évidemment
quatre rapporteurs ont été désignés pour
mener ces travaux les présidents de
chaque délégation Stéphane Artano et
moi-même ainsi que victoire jasmin et
elles achètent qui sont à sur ma droite
en présentiel au Sénat nous sommes
heureux ce matin d'accueillir Monsieur
Michel Villac Président et Madame et
mesdames Laurence Riou secrétaire
général et Camille chasserand
conseillère scientifique du Haut Conseil
de la famille de l'enfance et de l'âge
le HS le
hcfa c'est dur à dire
h CFA oui donc souvent il y a des
acronymes qui sont compliquées qui a
publié en mars 2022 un rapport intitulé
la situation des familles des enfants et
des fers personnes
âgées vulnérables dans les départements
et régions d'outre-mer Drôme réalité
sociale et politique menée monsieur
Claude Valentin Marie conseillé pour
l'outre-mer qui va qui est là voilà vous
nous avez rejoint sans que je vous ai vu
arriver
conseiller pour l'outre-mer auprès de la
direction de l'Institut national
d'études démographique l'Inde plus
simple nined qui publiera au printemps
la deuxième édition de l'enquête
migration famille et vieillissement dans
les départements et régions d'outre-mer
bienvenue à vous quatre
les représentants du Haut Conseil de la
famille de l'enfance et de l'âge nous
présenterons leur dernier rapport qui
met en évidence les spécificités des
structures familiales des dromes mais
aussi les différences par territoire et
recense une grande diversité
d'initiatives pour accompagner les
familles et en particulier les maires
seuls monsieur Marie blinette nous
présentera les objectifs et modalités de
la deuxième enquête migration famille et
vieillissement dans les départements et
régions d'outre-mer plus de 10 ans après
une première enquête qui avait rendu
possible l'analyse de données sur des
thèmes jusque-là inédit dans ces
territoires c'est vrai que pour apporter
des bonnes réponses il faut aussi que
les études soient menées et les enquêtes
également l'objectif était également de
mener des politiques publiques mieux
adaptées aux enjeux démographiques
spécifiques des drums il nous dira si
cet objectif a été atteint nous sommes
particulièrement intéressés par les
données que vous pourrez nous
communiquer pour cette première réunion
de nos deux délégations cher Stéphane au
cours de cette audition et ultérieure
sur les évolutions des structures
familiales dans les outre-mer et sur les
initiatives locales existantes en
matière d'accompagnement de la
parentalité donc je vais laisser sans
plus tarder la parole aux présidents
Stéphane Artano président de la
Délégation aux outre-mer qui intervient
à distance depuis Saint-Pierre et
Miquelon merci chers Stéphane pour ce
décalage horaire accepté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs et chers collègues étant
évidemment actuellement à
saint-pierre-et-miquant comme l'a
rappelé Annick et de retour d'une
mission avec le président du Sénat en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique participe à
cette première réunion visioconférence
et je vous prie évidemment de mon
excusée néanmoins les miracles de la
technologie nous permettent de pouvoir
travailler avec intelligence je me
réjouis à mon tour de cette perspective
de ce travail en commun ce n'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs que nous
l'expérimentons avec la délégation droit
des femmes et nous avons jusqu'à présent
une canonicité je rappelle notamment le
rapport conjoint en 2020 sur les
violences faites aux femmes sur la
direction du président Michel Magra et
de vous-même la présidente et nous
savons que problématiques doivent être
portées dans la durée et qu'il est utile
d'unir nos efforts nos colocs qui s'est
tenu récemment sur ce sujet à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui s'est
appuyé sur nos travaux montre à la fois
leur utilité bien sûr mais aussi tout le
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir sur ces
sujets de société concernant l'étude
avec Victor jasmin qui dispose de la
double casquette puisqu'elle appartient
aux deux délégations nous attendons
évidemment un état des lieux précis afin
de pouvoir
identifier le cas échéant les moyens
d'améliorer nos politiques publiques au
regard des
Ultramarines vous savez que notre
délégation est très engagée sur la
question de l'adaptation des dispositifs
et des normes évidemment sont préjugés
des résultats de cette étude il ne
serait pas surprenant que dans le
domaine de l'accompagnement à
parentalité comme dans bien d'autres des
rages ou des ajustements soit
souhaitables je vais pas être plus long
pour laisser la à nos experts des
collègues sur ce sujet très important
vous l'aurez compris pour comprendre les
défis auxquels marines sont actuellement
confrontés
merci beaucoup chers Stéphane et donc je
vais donner la parole immédiatement à
Monsieur Claude Valentin Marie qui va
brancher son micro et qui est le premier
intervenant pour cette réunion de ce
matin
à vous cher Monsieur et merci aux
membres des deux délégations présents ce
matin
bonjour je mets l'intervention
effectivement comme elle était demandée
ce rêve de vous indiquer un certain
nombre de travaux qui sont en cours
actuellement pour justement qui est une
reprise de l'enquête migration famille à
vieillissement que j'ai conçu à une aide
spécialement sur l'outre-mer et c'est la
première grande enquête de ce type qui a
été construit sur l'autre mer
le chant de de cette enquête c'était
plusieurs choses mesurées les magnets
diverses manières de faire famille dans
les dromes j'ai diverses manières de
faire famille dans les drones ce qui
signifie un point important c'est que
que ça soit la manière de faire famille
que ce soit les conséquences en termes
de parentalité ou que ça soit les
changements qui sont à l'heure que tous
ces plans il n'y a pas une vision
simplement commune de la situation des
dames et des situations extrêmement
différenciées c'est le point qui me
paraît extrêmement important à faire à
souligner immédiatement là-dedans
en fait l'ambition c'est sortir de cette
vision uniformisante des réalités des
drones et en particulier essayez de
faire atteindre et on verra ça tout à
l'heure avec Michel des aménagements qui
sont spécifiques aux réalités
spécifiques de chacun des territoires et
c'est ça la difficulté extrêmement
importante alors
l'objectif pour moi c'est de vous
montrer en quoi les familles tramarines
leur dynamique sont différentes d'un
territoires à l'autre de même que
l'adaptation des politiques publiques
doivent suivre cet élément
alors le temps que ça arrive parce que
je crois que ça marche pas pour
l'instant
alors je commence rapidement avec les
éléments reviennent si vous voulez
quelques traits saillants sur les
familles
ultramarines qu'il est distingue de
celle de la métropole d'abord vous
l'avez déjà dit tout à l'heure madame
des familles monoparentales en plus
grande non mais ne suivez pas de dire
qu'elles sont plus nombreuses pour dire
c'est la spécificité de cette famille
monoparentale c'est un des points
importants sur lesquels je vais revenir
tout à l'heure le deuxième point c'est
également des maternités précoces
beaucoup plus courantes des naissances
en mariage beaucoup plus courantes une
forte part de naissance
une fois par de naissance non reconnue
par les Pères et des cohabitations plus
durables des enfants avec les adultes
donc ce sont ces éléments et je vais
vous montrer en gros là qu'est-ce que
l'enquête nous permet de saisir donc
décidé voilà on a quatre grands axes
d'études à visés prospectives les
premières c'est les familles
ultramarines leur réalité leur
complexité
à l'intérieur de ça à la fécondité les
nucidités quels sont les évolutions de
comportement ce sont des points que leur
quête a étudié le deuxième sujet c'est
la question des migrations parce que la
question des familles s'articule très
profondément avec la question des
migrations qui elle-même
se distingue entre
l'aspiration au départ des jeunes
adultes c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est au cœur de réalité
extrêmement importante en Guadeloupe
aujourd'hui avec le départ de relou
permanence ne dépend de jeûne les
migrants retours qu'est-ce que j'appelle
migrants autour ce sont des natifs de
ces départements qui ont vécu plus ou
moins durablement à métropole et qui
reviennent à quelle date reviennent-ils
comment reviennent-ils comme Michael de
la conséquence et la troisième dimension
de ces migration qui concerne de manière
différenciée le département concernés ce
sont c'est l'arrivée des populations
immigrantes c'est-à-dire des non natifs
ou des étrangers qui s'installent dans
les territoires considérés
ensuite dans le vieillissement c'est
quelles conditions de vie et de
retraités et quels sont les liens
intergénérationnels comment évoluent-ils
justement lorsqu'on en a et c'est le cas
de la Martinique et de la Guadeloupe une
réduction de la natalité une diminution
du nombre des jeunes et une croissance
du vieillissement donc on a là des
enjeux qui effectivement
s'interpellaient
excusez-moi mais voilà donc l'enquête en
question est d'une ampleur importante
puisqu'on a enquêté 16000 personnes et
les spécifiques à chacun des territoires
avec plusieurs populations les natifs du
département les natifs de retour c'est à
dire ceux qui sont nés dans le
département qui ont fait un séjour à
l'extérieur généralement métropole qui
sont revenus leur parcours n'est pas le
même que ceux que ceux qui sont restés
et deuxièmement les immigrants et dans
les immigrants on distingue des
nationaux non nés sur le département qui
viennent s'installer dans le département
et les étrangers qui s'y installe et sur
ce plan je vais aller beaucoup plus vite
parce que ça je vais déjà dit sur ce
plan on remarquera que les dynamiques
sont extrêmement différentes et c'est ça
les premiers résultats qu'on a sorti
dans l'enquête précédente avec les
éléments qui correspondent aux éléments
que le recensement ou que l'état civil
peut nous donner la première chose c'est
une forte chute de la natalité
principalement aux Antilles
on est passé en gros si vous voulez en
Martinique en Guadeloupe d'une situation
dans les années 60 on s'affolait de la
natalité puisqu'on était dans une
moyenne de six enfants par femme à une
situation aujourd'hui ou le tout
l'indice de fécondité de moins de 2
enfants par femme il est de 9 à 8 à
Martinique ça veut dire quoi très
concrètement ça veut dire que dans une
continuation comme celle-là on n'a pas
de renouvellement de la population donc
on a là quelque chose d'une dynamique
extrêmement importante et ce qui est
important à souligner c'est pour ça que
j'ai mis en même temps la Guadeloupe et
la Martinique c'est que ça c'est quelque
chose de tout à fait remarquable
l'itinéraire à quelques années près à
quelques écarts
statistiques près la dynamique
guadeloupé se ressemblent totalement
donc il y en a quelque chose sur lequel
il faut réfléchir sur ces trois semblant
en terme de pensée d'une politique
publique qui serait différenciée
le second point c'est qu'effectivement
alors comme c'est pas animé mais ça ne
n'est pas là je vous l'expliquerai le
second point c'est l'accélération la
transition démographique en fait c'est
ce que je viens de vous dire c'est dire
qu'en fait on a un nombre d'enfants par
famille un homme d'enfants par femme qui
s'est fortement réduit et principalement
en Martinique en Guadeloupe et un peu
moins à la Réunion et en fait pas du
tout au contraire en Guyane et à Mayotte
je laisserai plus tard en gros si je
prends des familles qui étaient
installées en gros pas donc ils sont nés
c'est pas très pratique parce que
excusez-moi
si en gros je prends des femmes qui
étaient nées dans les années 30 à 39 on
a une situation où plus de la moitié de
ces femmes avait entre trois et plus
d'enfants principalement beaucoup avec
près de 6 enfants
et leurs enfants qui sont nés entre 60
et 69 c'est une situation exactement
l'inverse il est quasiment réduit de
moitié leur maternité donc on a là en
une génération basculement complet des
comportements de fécondité
je dis bien des comportements de
fécondité je ne parle pas des
comportements de nuptialité je ne leur
parle de couper les comportements de
parentalité donc ça juste et si vous
regardez bien vous voyez là ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est que la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique ont une
dynamique à peu près semblable
ces résultats ce sont les résultats que
nous avons mis en évidence il y a 10 ans
et en gros il y a 10 ans qui nous a dit
que aujourd'hui ça me disait prospective
et que 10 ans après c'est la situation
que l'on a la prochaine enquête va nous
permettre de faire le point sur la
question et en gros de nous indiquer
qu'est-ce que ça nous annonce pour les
10 ans qui viennent
la tendance est extrêmement forte à
l'inverse si vous regardez La Réunion
vous avez une situation qui ne manque à
la Réunion cette dynamique de réduction
de transition démographique elle a aussi
fonctionné à la Réunion mais avec une
degré beaucoup moins donc on n'est pas
du tout à la Réunion en termes de
natalité et également un verra plus loin
de structuration de la vie des familles
de la même situation que les Antilles
Mayotte aiguillian sont d'une situation
inverse puisque là au contraire on est
avec une forte natalité et on le verra
un peu plus loin et une natalité avec un
apport croisé inverse de celui des
Antilles c'est-à-dire avec une
immigration relativement importante
alors que doit-il nous sommes dans une
émigration relativement importante
la monoparentalité et ça c'est un point
sur lequel je voudrais pas mal insister
il est connu que le monde de parentalité
quelque chose qui est largement répandu
ce n'est pas une nouveauté par rapport à
ça ce que l'enquête a permis de voir
c'est les conditions et la spécificité
de la monoparentalité
précisément aux Antilles qui se
différencient des formes de
monoparentalité qu'on peut trouver en
métropole et qui se différencie aussi de
celle qu'on peut trouver à la Réunion je
m'explique non seulement nous avons une
part extrêmement importante de famille
de femmes qui sont en situation de
monoparentalité ayant un enfant élevant
seul mais ce qui est le plus important
et qui distingue la Martinique et la
Guadeloupe de la métropole mais
également de la Réunion c'est la durée
de vie de cette situation de
monoparentalité qui est non pas une moto
parentalité qui est une rupture de vie
de couple mais une entrée directe en
parentalité qui dure jusqu'à
l'adolescence de l'enfant
la grande différence n'est pas seulement
le taux de monoparentalité c'est les
modalités même de la monoparentalité qui
est d'autant plus dans cette
configuration que les familles sont
prêtes
donc dans la situation de parentalité on
cumule
l'absence du père et vous verrez plus
loin la non reconnaissance des enfants
par le père
à part importante une précarité des
mères
et une précarité des mers on va le voir
plus loin qui a une incidence concrète
sur la vie des enfants que ça soit dans
les premières années de la vie que ça
soit après la périnatalité dans le
parcours scolaire des enfants
donc on voit là quelque chose qui
distingue concrètement la situation
antillaise de la situation
métropolitaine mais qui la distingue
aussi de ce point de vue de la situation
mahoraise de la situation lui à l'aise
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure j'ai choisi cette
ce petit job de dessinateur de
l'humoriste Martigny qui est en
Martinique qui s'appelle Pancho
dis papa où sont les mamans c'est qu'en
fait effectivement la grande réalité
c'est que une part importante les
enfants ne sont pas reconnus par les
pairs
et ça du point de vue de l'organisation
de la vie familiale s'agit pas seulement
de la monoparentalité mais dans la non
reconnaissance des enfants
c'est un élément de plus dans
l'organisation sociale de la vie
familiale et les perspectives de vie des
enfants considérés vous avez les
éléments là-dessus là ce que je vous
donne comme élément date de 2019 ce sont
des éléments du rotation
troisième point que montrer déjà à
l'époque l'enquête il y a 10 ans c'est
l'importance des maladies des maternités
précoces et ce qui vous regardez sur ce
qui se passait il y a 10 ans qui annonce
d'une certaine manière ce qu'on aura
aujourd'hui les prochains résultats nous
donnons ça de manière différente c'est
qu'on avait des maternités précoces
d'une manière générale sont plus
importantes comme métropole mais qui
sont différenciés en termes de volume de
proportion entre les antices d'un côté
la Guyane et la Réunion de l'autre et
également Mayotte alors Mayotte n'était
pas dans ce travail puisque nous avons
fait l'enquête à Mayotte 58 heures les
résultats le Mayotte confortent d'une
certaine manière les dynamiques qui sont
ici étudiées
donc ce qui est important dans cette
affaire c'est qu'on a et tout à l'heure
que nous avons travaillé ensemble Michel
reviendra sur les conséquences que ça
peut avoir en terme de politique
publique à l'endroit de cette situation
des maternités précoces extrêmement
importantes qui s'accompagne je l'ai pas
présenté ici mais on le verra tout à
l'heure il s'accompagne de recours à
l'IVG qui était également extrêmement
important dans ces départements
la conséquence de cette affaire si j'ai
été clair jusqu'à présent et je prends
le cas des Antilles donc je vais pas
aller tout à l'heure c'est que nous
avons
chute importante de la natalité c'est le
petit carré que vous avez sur la gauche
qui s'accompagne donc si vous voyez sur
la pyramide par une réduction de la
pyramide par le bas il y a de moins en
moins de naissance
l'Asie nous avons à peu près une moyenne
de 10 000 naissances par an 60 nous en
sommes à 3700 aujourd'hui naissance par
an la réalité concrète de cette affaire
aux Antilles c'est que depuis à peu près
un an ou deux ans
ce qu'on appelle le seul de naturel et
c'est la différence entre le nombre de
naissances et le nombre de décès ce seul
de naturel aux Antilles il est négatif
il y a eu l'année dernière moins de
naissance qu'il n'y a eu de décès
et cet élément joue parce que vous avez
un deuxième élément qui est sur le carré
qui est à votre droite c'est-à-dire
l'effet de l'immigration c'est à dire du
départ qui sont principalement marqués
par le cours des jeunes qui font le
creux de la partie que vous voyez ça
veut dire que dans ce creux une grande
part des enfants qui sont tous
aujourd'hui principalement à métropole
mais ce que signifie aussi en même temps
et ça il s'accélère il s'agrandit que
vous avez une peur de la population en
âge d'activité qui pour une grande part
d'entre elles n'est plus disponible sur
le territoire
et en particulier comme cette migration
je détaillerai pas un caractère très
sélectif
si dans les années 60-70 la métropole
recevait et trouver à occuper des gens
de qualifications modestes dans les PTT
femmes de salle des hôpitaux etc cette
réalité d'aujourd'hui n'existe plus ce
qui signifie que la
migration l'émigrations au départ des
DOM est une migration tout le monde veut
partir mais tout le monde peut pas
rester en métropole la migration devenue
de plus en plus sélective ça signifie
concrètement que sont principalement
installé en métropole une grande part de
la jeunesse des territoires mais
principalement la partie la plus
qualifiée de cette jeunesse
à l'inverse
et là sont complètement gentilles pour
aller vers la Guyenne et Mayotte on est
dans un processus totalement inversé à
Mayotte c'est à dire avec une très forte
croissance démographique
qu'il soit que ça le soit amayote ou un
client et plus active plus importante
encore un meilleur il y a des effets
extrêmement concrets de cette croissance
démographique avec la densité sur le
territoire qui crée les conditions de
vie qui sont extrêmement délicates pour
ne pas dire plus de la situation
maraisse mais qui a pour caractéristique
commune offre Mayotte et la Guyane de
concilier ou de combiner deux éléments
exactement inverse de ce que je vous ai
décrit tout à l'heure une forte natalité
associée à une importante immigration
l'immigration est tellement importante à
Mayotte que en dépit que les jeunes
mèneraient je dis bien en dépit que les
jeunes Mahorais soient très nombreux
notamment en utilisant les éléments de
la dame et la possibilité d'être pris en
charge dans les pays qui soit très
nombreux à métropole
la situation des jeunes qui sont en
situation sur le territoire crée une
dynamique de précarité extrêmement
importante à Mayotte et ce point
alors excusez-moi ce soyez être activé
mais je vous ai fait ce graphique qui
est un peu confus quand on le voit comme
ça à droite vous avez la Martinique et
vous avez le creux dans le premier carré
qui est le départ des jeunes
à gauche vous avez l'exemple de la
Guyane qui est au contraire l'arrivée au
même âge de population immigrés
c'est la raison
alors ce qu'il faut regarder c'est les
petits cœurs qui sont en dessous
excusez-moi j'avais prévu de le faire
autrement la conséquence de cela c'est
que la dynamique qui anime les enjeux
démographiques en Guyane comme à Mayotte
c'est une dynamique non seulement de
croissance importante de la population
mais de recomposition interne de la
population avec une part de plus en plus
importante de population étrangère que
dans le territoire si vous regardez le
graphique vous avez 75% en gros de la
population vivant aux Antilles âgées de
18 à 79 ans ça en 2010 qui sont des
natifs des Antilles dont les deux
parents sont nés aux Antilles
vous avez ensuite alors je détaille pas
ce dont un seul parrain de nos Antilles
ceux qui sont les originaires j'appelle
originaires des gens qui des personnes
qui sont nés en métropole de parents
néo-zentis qui est à des migrants
métropoles et qui sont revenus avec
leurs parents qui n'est pas la fréquence
générale on les appelle nous dans notre
enquête les originaires des Antilles
mais ce qui est à garder comme élément
là-dessus c'est que sur la population
d'Antillais vous avez seulement 4% de
population étrangères qui étaient
installée en Guadeloupe et en Martinique
il y a 10 ans contre 45% de population
étrangères qui sont installés en Guyane
la situation est à peu près la même donc
vous avez là quelque chose qui est
une dynamique démographique qui du côté
des Antilles se traduit par une
réduction et un vieillissement de la
population
une situation d'immigration c'est à dire
l'inverse en juillet à la Mayotte qui se
traduit par une croissance importante de
la population mais une sorte de
recomposition interne de la population
et donc on a là des choses qui font que
la question des étrangers la question du
devenir des enfants d'étrangers ne se
pose absolument pas dans les mêmes
termes ne pose absolument pas les mêmes
questions ne soulève absolument pas les
mêmes enjeux que je réfléchisse à une
situation antillaise que je réfléchis à
une situation nuit à l'aise une
situation mahores
et voilà notre Mayotte qui est le lieu
de dynamique extrêmement prononcé ou se
croisent des jeunes qui quittent le
petit kit le territoire pour s'installer
en métropole pour des études qui peut
vivre à venir les natifs de retour se
sont ceux qui sont partis antérieurement
et qui reviennent sur le territoire et
vous avez surtout la part de ceux qui
n'ont jamais migré qui n'ont jamais
quitté le territoire natif de Mayotte
c'est seulement 23%, c'est tout à fait
un film par rapport à ce qui se passe en
Martinique en Guadeloupe mais à
l'inverse vous avez 47% en 2015
de natif parlant de personnes vivantes
la période qui sont non natives de
Mayotte principalement des populations
étrangères principalement l'origine
comorienne principalement d'origine
dangereuses et tous les débats que vous
avez aujourd'hui sur la situation
mahoraise et les difficultés
particulières sont liées à cette
dynamique extrêmement importante
d'autant que dans ce contexte là on a
des taux de natalités qui sont également
très élevés et des niveaux de précarité
qui sont également extrêmement élevés
cela se traduit par une croissance
démographique une densification
extrêmement forte de la situation de
Mayotte nous sommes avec une
concentration en particulier dans les
communes proches de la capitaine
Mamoudzou on est globalement à 600
habitants au mètre carré à Mayotte les
années rien à côté de situations très
particulière de certaines communes de
Mayotte qui créent des conditions de vie
et des conditions
d'éducation et de prise en charge des
enfants qui n'ont absolument rien à voir
ce qu'on peut avoir en Martinique en
Guadeloupe
je suis désolé ça ne marche pas bien
j'avais là ce graphique était de vous
montrer la contribution des maires
comoriennes à l'augmentation continue
des sens si vous regardez sur l'année
2011 si ma vie est bonne d'ici on a plus
de 10000 naissance dans l'année de 21
pardon et vous voyez que l'essentiel de
ces naissances sont des naissances de
maire que moyenne
donc vous avez par rapport à ça un homme
croissant d'enfants qui naissent à
Mayotte depuis ses 10 ou 15 dernières
années dont un et des parents au moins
je libère un des parents au moins
principalement la mer est étrangère
principalement comorienne principalement
en Juanes
une grande partie c'est la partie vert
foncé et verpal vert français c'est les
deux parents sont étrangers et vous
voyez que cette clientèle croissance
entre 2014 et 2019 la partie un peu plus
clair plus clair du gris du grisé ce
sont les enfants dans au moins un des
parents est né à l'étranger
principalement aux Comores
principalement la mer c'est cet enjeu là
autour duquel se joue aujourd'hui la
question du code de la nationalité
qui vise concrètement à une situation où
le doigt du sol pour ses enfants qui
sont nés sur le territoire français ne
vont sont mises en cause d'une certaine
manière sur la légitimité de leur
appartement à la communauté nationale
cet élément de croisement entre une
dynamique de natalité
consécutive à une dynamique
d'immigration
consécutive à une situation de
peuplement
consécutive à une recondition une
recomposition de la population matin
vivant sa Mayotte entre natif et non
natif c'est elle qui crée des situations
de violence de précarité exacerber et
qui nous amène aujourd'hui avec un enjeu
juridique de type constitutionnel
attention ce sont les enfants de Mayotte
que deviendront-ils dans les 15 à 10 ans
je voulais indiquer et vous voyez
effectivement que si je prends la si je
compare à la Guyane et Mayotte on est
différenciation très nette sur la
nationalité des parents on a une part
importante de nationalité étrangère mais
ne parle pas de cette nationalité
étrangère d'enfants qui sont venus sur
le territoire donc quel est l'enjeu
politique économique et sociale de cette
situation
contrastée entre une chute de natalité
qui risque de conduire un vieillissement
accéléré de la population les entiers
d'un côté
et les enjeux de parentalités qui s'y
attachent les changements de
comportement en termes de fécondité les
modalités de construction de la famille
dans cette réalité particulière salle de
côté de l'autre dans l'océan elle vient
alors extrême si je puis dire la
situation de Mayotte avec une situation
d'immigration extrêmement importante de
natalité en proportion nettement plus
importante un homme grandissant l'enfant
monsieur le territoire qui non seulement
sur les initiation de précarité en terme
de scolarité envers là-dessus mais dans
un devenir qui est avec un énorme point
d'interrogation et c'est une question
sur lequel j'aimerais beaucoup attirer
mon attention la conséquence pratique si
vous voulez c'est des scolarisation qui
sont plus courtes
qui sont plus moins précoces comparé à
celle des Antilles à Mayotte et en
Guyane principalement manioc et de
sortie
de l'appareil scolaire également plus
rapide pour les enfants qui se traduit
par dans les réseaux de 2019 par une
part importante de jeunes de ces
territoires de demain en général
spécifiquement pour les deux dont je
vous ai parlé plus précisément d'enfants
qui sont en difficulté de lecture voire
même qui sont la situation d'illettrisme
donc on a là quelque chose qui se
dessine de la naissance de la scolarité
à la sortie de la scolarité sans moyens
avec un doute pour certains sur leur
appartenance à la société dans laquelle
ils sont nés qui constitue une
configuration qui marque la spécificité
mahoresse qui commence à se faire
ressentir la même manière ce n'était pas
le cas il y a 10 ans comment ça se fait
ressentir la même manière mais qui n'a
rien à voir d'une certaine manière pas
de cette manière s'il n'a rien à voir
avec ce qui se joue en Martinique en
Guadeloupe ou à la Réunion
dans la scolarisation et je donne je
vais faire la même chose pour Mayotte je
vous donne ici une carte qui monte les
non seulement les inégalités globales
que je vous ai indiquées mais à
l'intérieur de ces inédites inégalités
globale qui touche la Guyane vous avez
les inégalités internes en fonction de
du territoire sur lequel les enfants
sont nés je n'ai pas du tout dit un mot
parce que c'est l'orchestre en question
ne prend pas encore cette population
pour les questions de difficulté de
l'enquête je n'ai dit je n'ai rien dit
des populations dites de l'Intérieur qui
sont aussi un enjeu important dont la
jeunesse aujourd'hui est en situation
elle-même aussi de forte précarité
l'enquête que nous avons fait ne dit
rien de cette population mais j'attire
quand même votre attention sur les
éléments et vous voyez donc que vous
avez une situation de nos scolarisation
qui varient énormément selon le
territoire où on se trouve et le
territoire principalement du côté de
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni qui est le
territoire sur lequel se trouve une
grande partie des étrangers qui signifie
qu'une grande partie des enfants qui
sont dans cette situation de nos
scolarisation sont les enfants
principalement les étrangers qui
viennent principalement le Suriname
dans ce schéma général la protection
sociale joue un rôle extrêmement
important
en particulier
pour les familles monoparentales
mais en dépit de cet apport
significatif de la protection sociale
elle ne suffit il ne suffit pas cette
accord à régler les inégalités et le
taux de pauvreté que nous avons dans ce
territoire merci
ben écoutez merci vraiment pour la
précision des données qui ont été
fournies et c'est vrai que ça nous
éclaire déjà extrêmement
je devrais j'ai promis une fois que la
nouvelle enquête est en cours
ça c'est en 2010 qu'est-ce qui est la
situation de 2020 qui en vaut annonce le
10 entiers
d'aujourd'hui ça a été fait il y a 10
ans quand les données seront prêtes je
vous ferai un petit rapport sur comment
dirais-je la mise à jour de ce que je
viens de vous indiquer
donc merci vraiment monsieur Marie parce
que ces données déjà nous éclairent et
on voit certaines spécificités et
certains traits se dégager et les
chiffres que vous avez donnés sont
extrêmement précis et nous donne déjà
des orientations de travaux je vais
immédiatement céder la parole au trio
Monsieur Michel Valak viaque pardon je
veux dire voilà qu'à chaque fois voilà
madame Laurence Riou et Madame Camille
chasserand c'est à vous la parole où
vous organisez comme vous le souhaitez
monsieur mesdames et on vous laisse tout
de suite si vous avez une projection
bien entendu vous la vous la passez
également j'espère que ça va bien
à vous monsieur viiac
Billag village une villa
alors
branchez votre micro peut-être et puis
moi le mien voilà voilà
donc merci beaucoup de nous avoir invité
je voulais commencer par la dernière
diapositive que vous avez que vous a
présenté Claude en
vous demandant de regarder la dernière
colonne en haut qui est la part des
personnes couvertes par la Sécurité
Sociale en % de la pourcentage de la
population et pour attirer votre
attention sur un élément le fait que
dans disons les les quatre
départements région anciens
on a des une part de la population
couverte par la Sécurité sociale qui est
supérieur à celle que l'on trouve dans
l'Hexagone et ceci tient à la au niveau
de vie enfin revenu limité de la
population
contre la situation à Mayotte ou je vous
le rappelle le niveau de vie à Mayotte
et un sixième de celui que on a dans
l'Hexagone donc un écart de niveau de
vie médian qui est extrêmement important
et pourtant seule un tiers de la
population et couverte par les
prestations familiales et sociales que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que les
dispositions qui sont prises qui dans le
code de la sécurité sociale et notamment
sur les types de prestations familiales
et sociales beaucoup plus restrictive
font que bien que les besoins soient
très importants
il n'y a qu'une part très minoritaire de
de la population qui bénéficie des aides
de la protection sociale de ce point de
vue là donc je voulais commencer par
insister là-dessus ensuite donc je vais
repasser alors donc sur le rapport que
que nous avons fait il y a eu trois
rapports faits par le Haut Conseil
puisque le Haut Conseil a trois conseils
en fait en son sein le conseil de la
famille je vais vous présenter ce que ce
que nous avons fait vous avez eu deux
autres rapports un qui a été fait par le
conseil de l'âge plutôt sur des
questions forcément de la dépendance et
limiter au département les plus âgés
c'est à dire Antilles et réunion et un
rapport sur l'enfance plutôt sur les
questions de santé
qui a été fait par le conseil de
l'enfance et là plutôt sur Mayotte
Guyane je sais plus et la Réunion bon
donc
nous nous sommes appuyés pour notre
travail sur d'abord sur un rapport
excellent café pour qu'on fait pour nous
Claude Valentin Marie ici présent et
Robert Antoine et donc le début de ma
présentation je vais le passer très vite
puisque c'est bien moins dit qu'il ne
l'a fait une synthèse de ce qui vous a
dit donc situation démographique
contrastée question des migrations avec
les natures différentes des flux avec
les entre les Antilles d'un côté Guyane
et Mayotte d'autre part des structures
familiales spécifiques avec la question
des familles monoparentales nombre
important de personnes seules ainsi de
suite et puis modèle particulier de
monoparentalité
je vais vite là dessus sur les tailles
de famille puisqu'il vous l'a indiqué la
question des grossesses adolescentes
plus fréquentes mais concentrée
aujourd'hui dans dans le territoire et
de même des IVG plus fréquents des
problématiques de violences
intra-familiales plus importantes et
puis des conditions de logement très
précaires pour une partie de la
population à Mayotte et en Guyane
qu'on trouve pas dans les autres un taux
de pauvreté élevé plus élevés que que
dans l'Hexagone et avec
de ce point de vue là deux départements
qui ressortent Mayotte d'une part je
vous l'ai dit et la Guyane a
un degré moins des inégalités de niveau
de vie extrêmement importante et puis
donc un niveau de vie plus faible
confronté à des prix qui sont en moyenne
plus élevé et donc une situation
d'autant plus tendue en termes de
pouvoir d'achat
des difficultés importantes pour les
jeunes en matière d'emploi de formation
des taux d'emploi plus faibles qu'en
métropole particulièrement Mayotte
aiguillian et puis ce que je viens de je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure sur les
conditions de logement avec notamment à
Mayotte une part importante de d'habitat
de fortune en gros de bidonville on va
dire comme ça alors par rapport à cela
que peut-on dire des politiques menées
et ensuite je viendrai sur les
propositions du Haut Conseil
sur les politiques menées en gros on a
observé au cours du temps une tension
entre d'un côté
une volonté une demande forte
d'harmonisation des prestations avec la
métropole et deuxièmement le fait de
maintenir des des règlements de station
spécifiques
justifiée en principe par les situations
locales particulières mais on y
reviendra particulièrement à Mayotte et
ça je vais insister sur ce point là
sur
concernant les prestations familiales ce
que l'on peut dire c'est que du côté des
quatre dromes historiques
le mouvement vers la lignement des
prestations
dans les drones concernés et l'Hexagone
a été conduit au cours du temps en gros
on était parti d'une situation dans
laquelle la logique était celle d'une
dite d'une parité sociale globale
c'est-à-dire que les prestations étaient
moins élevées mais en contrepartie il y
avait des crédits d'action sociale ainsi
de suite qui permettait de développer
des politiques complémentaires on est
allé vers une égalisation qui est pas
totale je vous indiquerai les points de
différence qui restent par contre ce
mouvement on peut considérer qu'il a pas
du tout été engagé en ce qui concerne
Mayotte qui reste beaucoup de
de chemin à faire de ce côté là
alors sur les prestations légales dans
les quatre
dromes historiques donc les prestations
familiales sont
identiques sauf
des allocations familiales au premier
enfant qui correspondent à
24,39 par mois en 2021 et puis deuxième
deuxième différence importante et on y
reviendrait c'est le complément familial
le complément familial qui n'a rien à
voir avec celui que l'on trouve dans
l'Hexagone en gros la vocation du
complément familial dans l'Hexagone
c'est une prestation qui s'adresse aux
familles qui ont au moins trois enfants
et qui ont un revenu modeste et donc il
leur permet de compléter leur niveau de
vie
en prenant la suite de ce côté là de la
prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant là
on a des conditions des clauses qui sont
totalement différentes sont de
s'intéresse plus du tout aux familles
d'au moins trois enfants ayant un niveau
de vie modeste par contre
elle il est versé pour les familles
ayant un ou plusieurs enfants entre 3 et
5 ans ce qui pose ailleurs des problèmes
de continuité par rapport à dans le
temps quand vous avez une nouvelle
naissance
quand vous avez une nouvelle naissance
le complément familial s'arrête bon donc
un complément familial qui est de nature
très différente qui correspond enfin
pourquoi cette différence si on essaie
de l'interpréter c'est l'idée on veut
pas encourager la natalité donc on veut
pas donner de prestation supplémentaire
aux familles ayant trois enfants au
moins Claude vous a indiqué l'évolution
de la fécondité de la taille des
familles cette cet argument n'a plus de
poids si je peux dire et puis d'un autre
d'un autre côté
les
prestations familiales en vocation à
aider les familles pour l'éducation des
enfants il y a aucune raison de penser
que un enfant parce qu'il vit dans un
département région d'outre-mer
bénéficierait d'une aide moindre de la
part de la connectivité que celle qui
est anti bénéficient quand il est dans
l'Hexagone
deuxièmement les prestations de
solidarité
RSA notamment sont identiques avec en
plus
une prestation mais qui concerne très
peu de monde qui s'appelle le revenu de
solidarité le RSO qui concerne les
bénéficiaires du RSA depuis au moins
deux ans
âgé de 55 à 64 ans qui s'engage à
quitter le marché du travail mais ça
concerne très peu de monde et puis les
aides au logement elles-mêmes qui sont
un outil important pour aider les
familles modestes sont différentes
la situation à Mayotte n'a rien à voir
à Mayotte en fait
seuls les allocations familiales pour
deux enfants
non moduler sont identiques à celles que
l'on trouve en métropole et puis il y a
deux prestations très très spécifiques
pour les enfants
handicapés notamment qui sont identiques
tout le reste est différent
il y a des prestations qui ne sont pas
servies la location de tient familiale
qui
est destiné
au mercure
la prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant
qui est quand même un des une des
prestations en termes de masse les plus
importantes en métropole et le RSE qui
qui n'existe pas à Mayotte
il y a quelques prestations qui ne sont
pas encore servies mais qui devraient
être
intégrer là de je sais pas si c'est déjà
le cas où dans les dans les mois qui
viennent c'est le congé
mode de garde qui qui aide les personnes
qui donnent leur enfant à garder par une
assistante maternelle et le congé
paternité d'accueil de l'enfant et puis
il y a toute une série de prestations
qui ont des conditions des montants
spécifiques il y a les allocations
familiales pour le premier enfant
identique à celle de des autres
départements les allocations familiales
à partir du troisième enfant sont à un
montant moindre de celui que l'on trouve
ailleurs le complément familial
[Musique]
l'ARS le RSA la prime d'activité la
location adulte handicapés les aides au
logement sont aussi avec des conditions
spécifiques et
moins favorable que celle que l'on
trouve dans l'Hexagone ceci explique le
les 32% enfin le fait qui est simplement
un tiers de de la population qui
bénéficie de prestations familiales ou
sociales notamment pour une raison c'est
que malgré le taux de pauvreté important
le RSA est pas du tout au même condition
que celle que l'on trouve ailleurs ce
qui peut se discuter enfin c'est il y a
pas de alors
un profil des bénéficiaires qui est
marqué par le poids de la pauvreté les
conditions d'attribution des différentes
prestations donc je vous ai montré sur
les taux de couverture
les
allocataires à bas revenus sont beaucoup
plus dépendants de ce qu'il perçoivent
de la part des caisses d'allocations
familiales que qui ne le sont en
métropole du fait de la pauvreté
une part importante de la population qui
est couverte par le RSA ce qui explique
des taux de couverture plus importantes
dans les autres départements mais pas à
Mayotte
et puis un profil spécifique pour les
dépenses de prestation familiales liées
à la spécificité des conditions
d'attribution
dans les différents départements
en ce qui concerne l'action sociale qui
est le qui est le complément
à l'initiative des caisses d'allocations
familiales ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que on a eu progressivement une
trajectoire de convergence là aussi
entre les orientations des politiques
d'action sociale menées dans les quatre
dromes historiques et celles menée en
métropole avec des structures de
dépenses comparables
un point qui fait l'objet de d'attention
forte
c'est la question de l'accueil du jeune
enfant dans lequel là l'offre est
nettement
inférieur à celle que l'on peut trouver
en
métropole et des grandes différences en
termes d'aide sociale à l'enfance et
puis une situation toujours hors norme
pour pour Mayotte
donc par rapport à ce constat quels sont
les les propositions faites par le Haut
Conseil derrière une
priorité générale qui est l'idée qu'on
peut pas si l'on considère qu'il s'agit
de départements à l'égal des autres et
il n'y a pas de raison de penser
différemment on ne pourra avancer que
avec un investissement important pour
réduire les écarts avec la métropole et
de ce point de vue là c'est pas des
prestations sociales des familiales qui
qui permettront de massivement de de
faire évoluer les problèmes structurels
de différence entre conditions et niveau
de vie que l'on trouve dans les dans les
dromes par rapport à l'exactérum c'est
il faut et ça c'est pas de notre ressort
bien évidemment les aspects
développement économique éducation et
formation et logements sont tout à fait
prioritaires et primordiaux et donc ceci
nécessite c'est pas de notre ressort
mais que
la collectivité
décide d'investir fortement pour essayer
de rétablir un temps soit peu les
équilibre sinon les raisons qui qui
expliquent les déséquilibres que vous
indiquez Claude tout à l'heure notamment
lié aux phénomènes migratoires toutes
les conséquences qu'ils ont resteront
pérenne et en maintenant leur
conséquences et puis bien entendu il y a
la question de l'immigration et
notamment Mayotte aiguillan comme Claude
voula voula indiqué
note la proposition qu'à prise le Haut
Conseil et de dire
les enfants mineurs il n'y a pas d'après
la convention des internationales des
droits de l'enfant on peut pas
considérer et on n'a pas le droit de
considérer que des enfants mineurs sont
en situation illégale et donc les
responsabilités de notre collectivité
vis-à-vis des enfants mineurs qui vivent
dans ces territoires doivent être les
mêmes quel que soit les
leurs conditions de vie leur origine
familiale et leur
et notamment sur un point qui est tout à
fait clé qui est la question de l'accès
à l'éducation
ce que l'on sait par exemple Claude l'a
montré sur
sur la Guyane mais ce que l'on sait par
exemple sur Mayotte c'est qu'il y a deux
très grandes difficultés
et c'est probablement un euphémisme pour
les mineurs non accompagnés pour pouvoir
s'inscrire à l'école et donc ce suit
ceci conduit est-ce que vous avez des
bandes inorganisées enfin organisé entre
de jeunes qui sont pas scolarisés qui
sont pas pris en main par par la
collectivité qui
font ce qu'ils peuvent et donc on se
crée en même temps un peu des bombes à
retardements de ce côté là
que l'on subira que l'on subit déjà
aujourd'hui qu'on subira à terme parce
que la probabilité que passait à l'âge
adulte ses enfants repartent et
relativement limité et donc il nous
paraît important sur ce sujet là que la
collectivité assume ses responsabilités
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des enfants quel
que soit leur situation
alors les propositions du Haut conseil
c'est première c'est verser les mêmes
prestations familiales
aux familles quel que soit le territoire
où elles habitent donc et notamment pour
nous la priorité c'est les compléments
familial qui est vraiment la prestation
qui aide les
les familles à partir de trois enfants
qui est vraiment une une prestation de
niveau de vie extrêmement importante il
est important que elle puisse être
attribuées dans les mêmes conditions que
ce qu'elle est dans l'Hexagone
concernant Mayotte vous voyez qu'on est
très très loin alors il y a des
engagements qui ont été pris de
convergence mais
on n'a pas et notamment vis-à-vis de la
population deux calendriers ferme précis
indiquant voilà
que l'on va faire dans quel délai de
quelle manière on va progresser la
première
proposition et de dire que il faut un
engagement beaucoup plus précis sur le
calendrier de convergence et notamment
sur la convergence concernant
les prestations familiales avec en
priorité l'allocation de la base de base
de la page des allocations familiales et
le compliment le complément familial en
demandant
chemin très rapide vers
la situation des autres départements et
ce calendrier doit préciser des
modalités de convergence pour les autres
prestations sociales on comprend bien
que notamment compte tenu des des écarts
de niveau de vie
aligné par exemple le RSA
à Mayotte sur celui qui existe en
métropole n'aurait pas de sens par
contre
conserver en tête l'idée de parité
sociale globale c'est une autre affaire
c'est à dire dire ok on verse pas des
prestations à ce niveau-là mais les
habitants du territoire ont droit à ce
titre-là un certain nombre de mesures
qui vont venir en termes d'action
sociale d'investissement ici ou de là
pour faire que les le territoire soit
aidé dans des conditions comparables à
ce que le son des autres les autres
territoires de la République
un point important pour nous c'est celui
de faire entrer Mayotte dans le droit
commun et en particulier
un point sur lequel on a insisté
plusieurs fois c'est que toutes les
dispositions en termes de notamment de
prestation familiales prises concernant
Mayotte sont prises par ordonnance elles
sont prises par ordonnance ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que il y a une
autorisation en général très vague qui
est donnée au gouvernement de pouvoir
traiter par ordonnance et ensuite il y a
aucune discussion au Parlement sur la
légitimité la justification ou pas de
maintenir un mode de traitement
différent pour tel ou tel prestation
d'un tel ou tel territoire par rapport à
ce qui existe dans l'Hexagone et pour
nous ça ça nous paraît une question
fondamentale sinon c'est
l'administration qui
qui décide ce qu'elle veut en fonction
de ses impératifs et donc il nous paraît
fondamental d'insister sur ce point-là
c'est que il faut sortir notamment pour
Mayotte de la
réglementation par ordonnance
et donc toute disposition de nature
législative doivent être prises par
après examen par le Parlement en évitant
le recours par des ordonnances et puis
il y a une particularité
qui nous a notamment choqué c'est que le
régime général de sécurité sociale
s'applique partout sauf
un régime autonome
un régime autonome est donc si vous
voulez demander au régime autonome de
Mayotte d'être équilibré c'est
se moquer du monde et donc si vous
voulez on demande pas à la Lozère aux
Pyrénées-Atlantiques ou à d'autres
départements d'avoir un équilibre entre
les recettes et les dépenses on sait
bien qu'il y a une mutualisation qui est
faite sur l'ensemble du territoire et
donc pour nous il est important que
Mayotte rentre dans le cadre du régime
général de
sécurité sociale qui couvre tout le
monde
pour nous un des points qui est pas
symbolique qui est tout à fait
importante pour les enfants c'est le
sujet de l'accès à un repas chaud au
moins à midi alors il y a en Presti en
principe une prestation qui qui existe
dans les drones qui s'appelle la
prestation d'aide à la restauration
scolaire donc qui est une aide qui est
qui est versée
aux communes mais il faut avoir accès à
la restauration scolaire et donc tous
les gamins qui n'ont qui sont soit dans
des communes où il y a pas d'offre à la
matière soit
qui sont dans des systèmes on trouve ça
dans certaines communes j'ai en tête par
exemple c'est pour probablement pas le
le seul exemple quand
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni ou ils ont le
pour comme problème de capacité scolaire
pour accueillir tous les enfants on a un
principe de demi-journée c'est à dire
une moitié des enfants sont scolarisés
le matin l'autre moitié l'après-midi et
entre les deux il y a pas de cantine
voilà donc il est important que tous les
enfants et pas puissent avoir accès à un
repas chaud et pas simplement à une
collation c'est à dire c'est un petit
bout de pain et une pomme ou quelque
chose comme ça
mais puisse avoir accès au moins un
repas chaud une fois par jour et que
donc
c'est des dispositions soient prises en
[Musique]
la matière et éventuellement mettant en
place des dispositions alternatives là
où il n'y a pas de de service de
restauration scolaire
bon
le logement n'est pas dans notre cœur de
de chauffe on est obligé c'est un point
tout à fait fondamental pour les
familles savoir les conditions de
logement et on ne peut pas continuer à
laisser subsister
alors c'est très inégal selon les les
départements c'est massif à Bayonne
c'est très important en Guyane ça allait
beaucoup moins
ça les moins dans les autres
départements à l'exception de certains
quartiers mais il faut vraiment qu'un
investissement très important qui soit
fait en matière de réception de
l'habitat insalubre il y a des rapports
tout à fait documentés en la matière qui
l'ont donné lieu qu'à des mises en œuvre
extrêmement limitées et puis il y a la
question du déploiement de de l'aide
personnalisée au logement dans les dans
les cinq drones
parmi les autres propositions s'il y a
l'idée de développer des programmes
d'accompagnement à la parentalité
orienter notamment là où c'est
nécessaire vers la prévention des
grossesses précoces et des grossesse
sont non désirées il y a la question du
non recours au prestations qui est assez
importante et qui tient notamment soit
au fait que enfin au fait que les
populations soient ne connaissent pas
l'existence de tel ou telle prestation
sont trop éloignées pour pouvoir
la demander il y a la question de la
scolarisation donc sur laquelle j'ai
assisté tout à l'heure notamment sur la
Guyane et sur encore plus sur Mayotte
voilà ce que je pouvais avoir à vous
présenter en complément de
du panorama que vous a tracé Claude
Valentin Marie
peut-être vous souhaitez compléter non
non
elle m'en mandatée pour parler à leur
nom mais elles sont plus compétentes que
moi en général pour répondre aux
questions que vous allez poser bon
puisque nous avions une tribune
paritaire j'en profitais pour donner la
parole aux femmes également cher
messieurs on va écouter si le si vous
souhaitez vous préférez répondre aux
questions à la fois des rapporteurs et
des membres des délégations présents on
va immédiatement passer aux questions et
sans plus tarder sauf si Stéphane qui
est en visio avec nous souhaite d'ores
et déjà intervenir on va passer aux
questions des deux rapporteurs sinon
présent en séance à toi Stéphane
je te remercie je te remercie présidente
merci de la qualité de vos interventions
mais il y a quelque chose qui m'a
intervenu monsieur villa qui il y a
beaucoup de choses qui m'ont interpellé
en l'occurrence mais je serai la parole
aux autres rapporteurs et puis ça nous
permet de mieux servir un petit peu le
grillé l'objet du rapport sur le
non-retour aux prestations par exemple
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'interpelle
et
je me questionne de savoir si il y a des
associations d'accompagnement avant
d'arrêter sont suffisamment impliqués ou
implantés en outre-mer je sais qu'il y a
des projets qui ont qui ont eu lieu dans
certains territoires mais pas dans tous
et de votre point de vue les uns et les
autres est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
devrait nous favoriser et de quelle
manière on pourrait favoriser
l'accompagnement à la parentalité sur
les meilleures connaissances
effectivement des dispositifs alors s'il
relève des cas évidemment les cas font
certainement des actions mais peut-être
au sens plus large le secteur associatif
est également peut-être une voie
d'entrée sur l'accompagnement
parentalité donc c'est un questionnement
que je vous livre dès maintenant et je
laisse la parole je suis la présidente
aux autres
merci monsieur le Président donc
peut-être que si vous pouvez noter les
questions parce que sinon on arrive
souvent à plusieurs questions qui sont
un petit peu identiques donc ce que je
propose c'est que on laisse intervenir
les deux rapporteurs en séance elles
achètent et victoire jasmin et peut-être
qu'on prendra toutes les questions si
elles sont pas trop nombreuses pour que
vous puissiez ensuite mesdames et
messieurs répondre à toutes ces
questions donc je vous propose de noter
les interrogations et que vous
répartirez en fonction de vos sujets de
prédilection ou de compétences
particulières donc qui démarre au niveau
victoire allez victoire jasmin
rapporteur madame la rapporteur oui
bonjour bonjour à tous et merci beaucoup
merci pour tout ce que vous avez déjà
donné comme information et vraiment je
crois que ce n'est probablement pas
exhaustif mais cependant je retrouve
dans vos différentes interventions la
vraie vie la vraie vie des territoires
que je connais voilà Guadeloupe en
particulier mais pour avoir été avec la
scénariste de la Guyane en Guyane
sur une mission qui avait été commencé
par nos collègues rigolotti et Karam
au moins en fait je ne connais pas
totalement ce qui se passe en Guyane
mais nous avions travaillé sur cette
problématique que nous avons vu aussi
parce que nous sommes déplacés à
Saint-Laurent pour Mayotte je viens mais
pour Mayotte ça reflète évidemment les
travaux qui ont été initiés et les
préoccupations de notre collègue tany
Mohamed sali qui a eu l'occasion de
faire légiférer justement sur le loi du
sol mais qui a très souvent interpellé
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée sur les
difficultés et les problématiques alors
conséquences sur Mayotte et nous avons
récemment lors du congrès des mains de
France à la première table ronde de
l'Association des maires de France pour
les autres mères il y a eu un et la
députée de une des députés en tout cas
de
Mayotte a lancé un cru d'alarme face à
ce qui était en train de se passer
à la violence et les liens étaient faits
directement avec ses préoccupations en
tout cas et tout ce que vous venez
d'évoquer donc tout cela pour vous dire
que
en tant que parlementaire je suis très
très impliqué aussi en Guadeloupe au
niveau associatif et ce que vous avez
dit reflète également la situation la
situation de la non reconnaissance des
enfants et de leur identité ça a même
fait l'objet de nos voyageries sont sur
cette situation il est en conséquence
sur les enfants eux-mêmes au niveau
psychologique les conséquences également
de
Dieu pense depuis le bumidum jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les départs massifs de
personnes pour venir travailler là vous
l'avez dit également ici l'hexagone et
les difficultés aujourd'hui
que nous rencontrons à la fois par
rapport au départ massif de la jeunesse
et notre collègue qu'on a fait un
travail aussi sur ça avec son
association mais en Guadeloupe aussi
mais elle est retombée ne sont pas
forcément pour le moment et important
donc ce sont des sujets qui sont
préoccupants et je vais aussi à
remercier madame la présidente de la
délégation du droit des femmes et le
président de la délégation outre-mer
pour le choix de cette action et j'ai eu
l'occasion il y a quelques jours
dimanche matin j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire également
au président Gérard Larcher qui était de
passer en Guadeloupe et le cri de
l'alarme je dirais il a l'air même
du maire de la ville de Pointe-à-Pitre
m'a permis justement de d'évoquer les
travaux que nous allons Lyon commencer
que nos débutants aujourd'hui donc c'est
important j'ai moi je suis
formé en santé publique et aussi j'ai
été cadre de santé au niveau
professionnel sérieux donc je me suis
toujours intéressé problématique lié à
la santé à tous les niveaux et j'ai été
président de fédération par l'élève je
suis maire de trois enfants et le schéma
en fait
la petite illustration de Monsieur Marie
ça m'a fait penser aussi ma famille
parce qu'on est cet enfant et aucun des
7 de ma famille en fait ma mère a eu mes
parents ont eu cet enfant mais bien
personne n'y arrivait à Sète chez moi
dans ma famille
donc c'est pas manque de courage et puis
peut-être que bon nos conditions de vie
et puis notre façon d'appréhender les
choses on a permis quand même de prendre
conscience que bon à l'époque de nos
parents il n'avaient pas tous les moyens
que nous avions donc mais cela pose de
vrais sujets de vrais problèmes aussi au
niveau économique au niveau du logement
il y a eu un des barycentre
sur le logement au Sénat sur le logement
notre mère donc il y a beaucoup de
conséquences et moi je souhaiterais
vraiment que pour ce qui nous concerne
et sur cette problématique en
particulier que nous puissions d'une
part
bénéficier des apports qui sont les
vôtres parce que vous avez non seulement
l'expertise nous a aidé donné qui nous
permettent évidemment de bien prendre
conscience nous et nos collègues parce
que je suis de la Guadeloupe je vois ce
qui se passe et je vois qu'il y a une
grande corrélation entre ce que vous
vous venez de nous évoquer et ce que
nous présentiez et la vie de tous les
jours mais les conséquences aussi on les
voit parce qu'on est dessus donc moi ce
que je vais vous proposer comme question
il y a eu un certain nombre de
dispositifs même si on met le fait qu'il
y ait des disparités il a nous le disons
souvent ici ce n'est pas forcément bien
compris ou perçu par nos collègues et
vous concerne disparité mais avec les
politiques publiques on a quand même pu
avoir les réseaux d'écoute d'appui à
l'accompagnement des parents on a eu un
certain nombre de dispositifs et
d'accompagnement avec les travailleurs
sociaux alors pourquoi justement nous en
sommes là il y a également la formation
à la formation au niveau qu'on également
la mise en adéquation des formations par
rapport aux besoins des territoires pour
qu'on nous étudiants sont encore obligés
de de partir alors qu'il y a
l'université il y a quand même certains
nombres de
dispositions un peu partout sur les
différents territoires qui sont quand
même on dit
ultramarin mais qui sont répartis sur
deux parties différentes de la planète
et nous ne sommes pas très très proches
il y a de grandes disparités dans
l'approche et vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Marie ainsi que vous aussi monsieur
Villac sur chaque des territoires il y a
quand même des particularités donc
trouver les éléments qui nous
permettraient des meilleurs options
possibles pour changer les tendances
tant au niveau de
du taux de naissance
accompagner différemment parce que
beaucoup de jeunes il faut dire
également qu'il y a des jeunes qui ont
et qui sont victimes aussi léopard ou
leur mère en tout cas ont été victimes
de traitement qui n'ont pas fait
facileiter le fait qu'elle puisse
elle-même pour créer beaucoup de jeunes
en âge de pour créer n'ont pas pu pour
créer sur certaines générations
parce qu'il y a eu un moment donné que
ce soit avec de l'humidité de
conséquence et on le voit aujourd'hui et
chez nous les alors il y a les les
situations extrêmes parce qu'il y a des
taux des végé importante très important
il y a eu des données récentes qui ont
été publiées donc ce n'est pas glorieux
non plus mais en même temps on voit
qu'il y a beaucoup de jeunes familles
donc en fait de couple qui souhaitent
avoir des enfants et qui n'ont pas sur
le territoire qui n'ont pas sur place
sur les territoires les possibilités
justement de bénéficier
des mesures qui pourraient leur être
proposées voilà donc maintenant
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire parce
que des modes de gardien des difficultés
des difficultés on trouve pas au stand
de de garderie que ce sera au niveau
communal ou même privé les normes celles
qui existaient les dents vont changer il
y a beaucoup de difficultés de mode de
garde il y a également les hérissons
économiques et en même temps
ces raisons économiques ne peuvent pas
tout excuser parce que en Guadeloupe
vous avez parlé de par exemple pour
Mayotte et pour la Guyane de
l'immigration mais il y a aussi
au niveau des de la communauté haïtienne
chez nous il y a des naissances
également donc là je ne sais pas si vous
avez des données concernant notre
territoire sur le nombre d'années de
femmes haïtiennes ou de dominicaine ou
de dominicaine sur nos territoires qui
sont quand même aussi
présente donc je ne suis peut-être que
ça ne représente pas les mêmes tons et
enfin
la dernière la dernière des choses c'est
aussi au niveau alors vous parlez du
niveau économique donc il y a
effectivement les différentes aides
sociales mais aussi l'emploi parce qu'il
y a le fort taux de chômage chez nous et
certains de nous jeunes pas pour faire
des études ils font les mêmes études que
que nous nos enfants et des familles de
l'Hexagone sont dans les mêmes
universités mais au moment du retour à
l'emploi ou de revenir sur les
territoires et bien les postes ne sont
pas forcément
mais à disposition une bénéficie pas
d'un certain poste auxquels il pourrait
prétendre donc je m'arrête à ce stade
donc ce sont aussi ces questions là qui
contribuent également à pérenniser
malheureusement ces situations mais ça
ne peut pas non plus tout expliquer mais
je félicite vraiment vous interventions
parce que on reflète vraiment réalité
que nous connaissons merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
rapporteur cher victoire je vais tout de
suite passer la parole à Elsa rapporteur
sur ce dossier ensuite nos collègues qui
sont présents et qui représentent de
nombreux territoires ultramarins
enchaîneront donc notez bien les
questions mesdames et messieurs voilà
merci madame la Présidente alors à mon
tour de vous remercier pour l'ensemble
de votre présentation et pour les
chiffres à la fois exhaustifs mais
également précis que vous nous avez
livré et je crois que c'est important au
moment où nous débutons nos travaux sur
cette question au combien importante de
la parentalité dans dans les outre-mer
que nous puissions justement commencer
par cet état des lieux et par ce constat
et à mon tour comme ma collègue victoire
jasmin je tiens à remercier monsieur le
président Stéphane Artano mais également
madame la Présidente billon d'avoir fait
de ce sujet justement un sujet commun
des deux délégations parce qu'on sait à
quel point c'est aussi important d'avoir
ce regard croisé et pour des personnes
qui j'avouent comme moi ne sont pas
forcément toujours au fait d'une
actualité précise en dans les DOM-TOM et
ben je pense que justement pouvoir se
plonger et avoir ce regard là c'est
aussi un élément extrêmement important
alors pour venir sur les questions alors
moi je serai assez brève parce que il y
a deux sujets qui m'ont particulièrement
interpellé notamment sur la question en
fait des grossesses précoces et sur ce
taux très important de grossesse précoce
comment l'expliquer vous si vous pouvez
l'expliquer
d'autant plus que si je vois bien dans
la différence enfin dans les
présentations que vous nous avez faite
on assiste d'une part un phénomène de
scolarisation évidemment plus courte
notamment pour pour les mères de famille
couplé à un autre phénomène qui est
celle de d'une offre d'accueil d'enfants
qui est peut-être moindre ou en tout cas
vous pointez des différences avec la
métropole d'où ma question quelles sont
ces différences par rapport à l'offre
d'accueil des jeunes enfants et ce que
justement ce phénomène est couplé on a
une scolarité plus courte des jeunes
filles parce que on a des offres
d'accueil qui sont peut-être moindres et
qui fait que du coup elle reste à la
maison pour pouvoir élever les enfants
puisque derrière cette question ce qui
est sous-jacent aussi c'est la situation
économique de ces jeunes femmes et ce
qu'elles peuvent justement à un moment
retrouver le chemin soit des études
puisqu'on voit bien que le taux de
grossesse avant 20 ans donc de manière
très jeune et importante donc est-ce
qu'elle retrouve la voix des études ou
en tout cas une possibilité d'insertion
dans la vie professionnelle et donc
merci également pour vos propositions
puisqu'on voit bien en fait que vous
proposez notamment un développement du
programme d'accompagnement à la
parentalité est-ce que vous avez des
pistes plus précises justement par
rapport à cette accompagnement à la
parentalité notamment par rapport à
cette question de la prévention des
grossesses précoces et puis j'avais une
question
concernant en fait la
nos parentalités parce que j'avais lu
dans la synthèse de votre apport de
manière très précise à la page 14 que le
modèle particulier de la monoparentalité
de plus en plus fréquent depuis au moins
une dizaine en fait d’années en
particulier en Guyane et à la Réunion et
donc je voulais juste savoir si un
changement c'était opéré il y a 10 ans
enfin comment vous expliquer que depuis
10 ans maintenant ce phénomène en fait
c'est accentuer et se développe je vous
remercie
alors une fois qu'on a passé les
questions des rapporteurs je vais donner
la parole à deux collègues qui sont en
présentiel et donc tout d'abord la
sédatrice qui représente la Guyane ce
Guyane ce matin donc à vous chers
collègues
merci présidente messieurs dames merci
beaucoup pour votre présentation alors
j'ai une question juste une question
mais je vais quand même vous dire que en
ce moment en Guyane et un sujet
important c'est ce sont les
dysfonctionnements dans les familles
d'accueil
on en parle beaucoup d'ailleurs pour ne
pas citer Mediapart à fait une enquête
auprès de auprès de jeunes qui sont
placés dans les familles d'accueil sur
le littoral donc des jeunes puisque on
revient d'ailleurs on sort de la
commission continuité territoriale et la
difficulté elle est là donc il y a pas
de route il y a pas de de Monsieur Marie
connaît très bien le territoire et donc
ces jeunes puisqu'il n'y a pas de
collège il y a pas de lycée dans les
communes sont obligés donc d'être placé
dans des familles d'accueil sur le
littoral et ça rejoint également un
autre sujet qui est important aussi
puisqu'il s'agit de suicide des jeunes
Amérindiens parce qu'en fait ils ont été
positionnés dans des familles d'accueil
sur le littoral ils ont subi entre
guillemets oui des violences
sexuelles etc et donc quand il
reviennent chez eux ben ils n'ont rien
appris en fait ils n'ont pas évolué et
en fait il se posent des questions en
tout cas sur sur
sur leur vie et donc ma question puisque
j'ai eu l'occasion effectivement lundi
soir de discuter avec la ministre
délégué à l'enfant ce madame Charlotte
poubelle avec qui on a beaucoup discuté
et elle essaie de trouver des solutions
en tout cas des propositions pour mettre
fin à ses dysfonctionnements et donc ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Villac
donc votre instance au Conseil de la
famille de l'enfance et de l'âge est-ce
que vous vous avez prévu ou est-ce que
vous avez déjà mené une enquête sur
justement l'accueil de ces adolescents
dans les familles d'accueil voilà merci
beaucoup président merci chers collègues
chers Marie-Laure alors maintenant la
parole à la Guyane avec pardon la
réunion avec notre collègue Nassima d'un
dard qui souhaitait vous adresser une
question également donc la Réunion
voyage beaucoup ce matin merci
présidente et puis à vous également
merci j'ai envie de vous dire que ma
collègue l'a vous nous donnez la réalité
que nous vivons sur nos territoires mais
vous avez une autorité supplémentaire
sur la parole des élus parce que vous on
vous croit on croit en
vos chiffres alors qu'on doute alors
qu'on doute beaucoup en doute beaucoup à
chaque fois que nous prenons la parole
pour rappeler une réalité la réalité que
vous avez décrite c'est celle que nous
avons sur nos territoires ultramarins
des territoires les plus inégalitaires
de la France
inégalitaire pourquoi les plus
inégalitaires parce qu'entre les plus
hauts revenus ou on tient compte du
niveau de vie de la hausse des prix des
produits plus chers du modèle
de consommation export hexagone Europe
et nos territoires on tient compte de ça
avec un index de correction pour les
fonctionnaires et de l'autre côté
inégalitaire pour encore le public le
plus précaire les familles les plus
précaires et quand vous donnez les
chiffres sur les prestations familiales
et sociales et sur le minimum RSA vous
voyez
comment nous construisons nous-mêmes le
ferment le ferment
de ce que vous venez d'appeler bombe à
retard ou demain
écrisent passer et actuelle que nous
vivons de manière régulière dans dans
les domaines voilà la situation de nos
territoires ultramarins
vous vous nous donnez à lire par des
chiffres le cercle vicieux de la
précarité et de la précarité des femmes
et je remercie vivement la délégation
aux droits des femmes et le président
pour mener ensemble le regard croisé sur
le rôle de la femme de la famille de
l'éducation des enfants avec du vrai
développement
des territoires
et quand je dis développement c'est pas
seulement le développement économique
c'est le développement sociétal pourquoi
parce que nous sommes des Français et
que nous voulons défendre les valeurs
citoyennes françaises qui sont sur nos
territoires et qui font grâce à sa
diversité la richesse même
de ce que nous aimons de la France que
nous défendons parlementaire que nous
sommes modestement à notre petite place
ou à notre juste place
les chiffres appellent donc ce cercle
vicieux de la précarité sociale et
familiale de l'urgence sociale dans
laquelle se trouve les mers et les élus
constamment les collectivités
répondent plus à l'urgence sociale pour
corriger ces inégalités et c'est pour ça
que je vous parle de cercle vicieux
parce que l'État n'apporte pas mais
parce que nous-mêmes c'est peut-être
notre incurie collective à nous tous
nous n'avons pas donné suffisamment dit
suffisamment haut et fort que la France
met de l'argent mais mettons une bonne
fois pour toutes pour corriger un modèle
alors que nous continuons à enclencher
la violence sociale et les violences
intrafamilales je veux vraiment vous
dire ce que je pense en tant que
politique et en tant que françaises
réunionnaise c'est à dire que c'est le
modèle qui induit tout cela pourquoi y
a-t-il autant de grossesse précoce mais
parce que quand vous avez vécu dans une
famille avec des violences
intrafamilales le fait de devenir maman
ça vous donne un statut et vous devenez
femme seule et vous allez avoir
une survie financière
puisque vous allez toucher la location
femme seule que vous pourrez prétendre
avoir un logement puisque vous avez un
enfant et que vous serez prioritaire
de quoi ça quoi ça ou de des enfants qui
sont nés sur le territoire français de
maire comorienne puisque nous sommes à
Mayotte cela la plus grosse maternité
qui existe et donc trouvons vraiment les
moyens moi je suis pour que l'alignement
du RSA se fasse à Mayotte
dans les plus brèves délais pour éviter
qu'effectivement dans toute cette zone
indien océanique nous namenons des
difficultés ma question est celle là
est-ce que vous croyez vous que faire
émerger en termes de politique familiale
sociale
la l'identité indien océanique qu'on
pourrait accompagner est-ce que ça ne
serait pas aussi une réponse
tous ces mineurs isolés qu'on rencontre
à la carence éducative
qui est de mise dans nos territoires
aujourd'hui nous faisons des enfants
mais les maires ne savent pas les
éduquer
ils finissent par devenir un moyen de
revenus les enfants restent là pendant
toutes les vacances scolaires j'étais
président d'un département je peux vous
le dire à la Réunion et les parents
repartent eux à Mayotte voire parfois
aux Comores et il y a de la carence
éducative que que
qu'au fond nous mettons nous-mêmes en
place parce que nous nous refusons de
voir une vraie réalité et d'apporter les
vraies réponses à des choses que nous
connaissons je me tais mais donc voilà
et puis ma deuxième question c'était sur
le RSO il me semble mais vous allez me
répondre le RSO persiste ou également
par exemple à la réunion nous sommes en
train de le de le réduire puisque les
gens sont restés dans le RSE au-delà de
65 ans
et on les oriente aujourd'hui vers le
minimum vieillesse et donc on a le
département de La Réunion accompagne
plus ou moins ça et peut-être une petite
suggestion pour être à la page 14 de
votre document plutôt que d'écrire les
resto ALG de 55 à 64 ans qui s'engagent
à quitter le marché du travail ça n'est
pas véritablement ça le RSE se sont ceux
qui sont in employables c'est pas qu'il
s'engage c'est parce que leur in
employabilité a fait qu'on a mis en
place un revenu RSO spécifique dans les
doms alors que ça n'existe pas sur la
France hexagonale ou métropolitaine et
donc voilà si peut-être juste cette
petite correction voilà je m'excuse mais
voilà j'essaie deux questions
on avance dans les questions merci à la
Réunion et Nassima pour toute l'énergie
et la foule qu'elle a dégagé dans son
intervention sans que c'est un sujet qui
passionne donc on va passer l'apparence
à la Nouvelle-Calédonie maintenant
Gérard potia qui est avec tout ce matin
merci
madame la Présidente moi je veux vous
remercier Madame et messieurs pour les
informations que vous avez apportées
aujourd'hui c'est quand même assez des
informations assez précises sur sur le
sujet je vais aussi remercier le
président de nous avoir associé notre
mission à cette à ce sujet qui qui nous
tient à cœur parce que dans les
outre-mer c'est pas toujours simple
on ne dit pas qu'il y a une différence
entre les êtres humains et l'Hexagone
mais
on estime qu'on est assez éloigné donc
on a un peu plus de difficultés
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
mes collègues des outre-mer pour dire
que il faut impérativement que la
République
prête une attention particulière sur le
sujet en outre-mer et quand je parle des
Outre-mer c'est l'ensemble des Outre-mer
c'est pas uniquement la
Nouvelle-Calédonie ni uniquement le
bassin Pacifique
même si je
j'ai une fierté de dire que l'avenir se
jouera en outre-mer et particulièrement
dans le Pacifique ce que je souhaite
comprendre déjà parce que mais en fait
ma collègue mes collègues ont fait
comprendre que beaucoup sont des enfants
on va dire des défis meurs on va dire ça
comme ça
et moi j'aimerais bien connaître le taux
en pourcentage de ces de ces films
mais en plus avec j'ai cru comprendre
que ils ont énormément de difficultés
puisque
pour moi la vie s'arrête là dès lors
qu'ils ont un
enfant il voit plus il ne faut plus un
effort pour aller plus loin quoi
c'est là où je
[Musique]
pense qu'il y a le nécessité
d'un développement économique et social
sur l'ensemble des territoires et ça
correspond à au sujet dans lequel nous
étions
juste avant
cette rencontre sur la continuité
territoriale
pour permettre la population
de vivre chez elle on ne peut pas passer
outre le développement et l'aménagement
du territoire
donc il y a une nécessité
pour nous quand je dis pour nous c'est
aussi bien l'état et l'ensemble des
ministère concernés de faire le point
avec les collectivités
locales
moi ce que j'aimerais bien par exemple
connaître c'est que nous on a des
caisses on a une caisse sociale autonome
mais comment ça se passe au niveau des
Outre-mer enfin de débarquement des
régions est-ce que c'est l'État qui
dirige directement est-ce que c'est il y
a une certaine autonomie tout ça c'est
c'est important enfin même si je suis
quand même de l'autre côté c'est
toujours important pour nous de
comprendre comment ça ça fonctionne quoi
donc voilà désolé mais bon je vais
devoir vous quitter parce que j'ai le
l'obligation à 11h mais je compte sur
les rapporteurs et je compte beaucoup
sur sur les deux commissions merci
t-shirt alors la parole de remet
Saint-Barth avec notre collègue
Micheline Jacques et ensuite il y aura
une dernière intervention avec Viviane
Manet toujours on retourne à la Réunion
merci merci président de mes chers
collègues permettez-moi de vous
remercier pour vos propos vraiment très
éclairant j'aurais plusieurs questions
la première question
nous allons parler d'immigration et le
lien entre la grossesse et le doigt du
sol puisqu'il ne faut pas se voiler la
face il y a aussi des des jeunes filles
qui qui arrivent sur le territoire
français et que la grossesse leur permet
justement de bénéficier de ce doigt du
sol
pourrait-on envisager de développer
l'éducation à la sexualité et les
plannings familiers aussi puisque la
plupart de ces jeunes ne sont pour
certaines illettrés donc que mettre en
place pour pouvoir les accompagner et et
enfin je rejoins ce que vous dites sur
le logement les conditions des centres
donc c'est un sujet que j'ai que j'ai
pris à bras le corps parce que j'estime
qu'il faut comme vous l'avez fort bien
expliqué sur la taille des fratries on
ne peut pas appliquer il faut adapter le
logement
en fonction des territoires et des
critères sociaux et pour l'instant ce
n'est pas le cas donc c'est vraiment
je ne dirais pas une bataille que je
mène mais j'essaie de faire comprendre
l'impériose nécessité d'adapter le
logement au caractéristique aux
spécificités de territoire et quand vous
avez une fratrie de 6 enfants et la
période le confinement covid la bien
montré on ne peut pas les loger dans un
même logement social que l'on peut loger
que l'on trouve dans l'Hexagone voilà
c'était le sens de mon propos et je vous
remercie beaucoup chers collègues et
donc Viviane Mallet pour terminer oui
merci
monsieur le Président
chers collègues et je les remercier les
intervenants qui nous ont bien relatés
en fait la réalité du terrain quand on
la connaît et je n'irai pas à l'encontre
des propos de Nassima puisque l'on a
travaillé ensemble elle en tant que
président du département et moi en tant
que pendant des années adjointe aux
affaires sociales d'une grande commune
de La Réunion Saint-Pierre et alors ma
question j'irai à peu près dans les
mêmes le même terrain que le président
de la délégation outre-mer dans votre
proposition de la
lhfa c'est vrai que c'est difficile à
dire vous préconisez
de développer des programmes
d'accompagnement de la parentalité et
donc dans certains territoires dont moi
je vais parler pour le modèle réunion il
y a plusieurs actions déjà de mener à
destination des familles et des parents
alors il y a la PMI effectivement les
laps les maisons de parents les relais
d'assistante maternelle itinérants et
énormément de mesures quand même qui
sont mises en place mais comment faire à
votre avis pour qu'il soit mieux lisible
mieux identifié mieux coordonner
peut-être aussi pour qu'il y a un
parcours de l'enfant du début jusqu'à la
à la fin même l'adolescence et puis
surtout les rendre plus attrayants voilà
qu'elle est allé le sens de ma question
je vous remercie à vous chers collègues
alors on va passer aux réponses
messieurs et mesdames et donc peut-être
laisser la parole à ces dames en premier
lieu puisque elles se sont pas exprimées
dans le premier tour de table et donc
vous vous organisez comme vous le
souhaitez pour les la prise de parole
donc madame chasserand je crois souhaite
répondre à toutes ces questions plus
riches les unes que les autres à vous
madame je ne répondrai pas tout puisque
Laurence Riou a beaucoup de réponses
aussi à apporter sur d'autres enfin sur
un certain nombre de questions je
voulais revenir sur
la question du non recours aux
prestations le non recours aux
prestations on l'observe
particulièrement évidemment on l'a dit à
Mayotte mais parce que une partie de la
population n'est pas un couverte et on
l'observe aussi beaucoup en Guyane
et là il faut juste comprendre par quoi
ça s'explique quand vous avez un
territoire immense avec des des parties
enclavées quand on vous demande d'aller
dans une cave qui est à un endroit du
territoire qui peut être très loin et il
y a pas transport public que ça coûte
cher d'y aller qu'on vous demande des
papiers des papiers dans un dans un dans
un département où il fait 98% d'humidité
où il faut conserver les papiers où on
n'a pas du tout cette culture
habituelle de conserver un certain
nombre de papiers où il y a pas Internet
partout les choses sont relativement
compliquées c'est à dire qu'on le voit
depuis la métropole mais on n'arrive pas
à imaginer que c'est c'est très
compliqué même de faire des services
itinérants même de faire des caisses
itinérantes quand vous faites un service
itinérant donc il y avait des pirogues
itinérantes en Guyane mais les familles
ont aussi leur propre rythme de vie
elles ne sont pas forcément là lorsque
la pirogue passe et sont pas les
informations sur les services publics et
puis il faut comprendre aussi que
partout il y a un barrage de la langue
et donc de la compréhension du du
langage administratif et de ce que ce
qu'on demande
alors il y a des actions bien sûr sur
les différents territoires pour tenter
de résoudre ce non recours notamment
voilà on l'a vu c'est beaucoup de choses
itinérantes pour essayer d'aller dans
les territoires enclavés d'aller vers
les les parents et les et les familles
le après il y a d'autres problèmes dans
ces dans ces allées verts c'est que qui
le fait on a une grande particularité je
trouve des territoires d'outre-mer qui
leur donnent aussi un attrait très
important c'est la densité du tissu
associatif et le dynamisme du tissu
associatif
qui est à la fois menée par des grands
opérateurs d'un côté mais aussi beaucoup
par des initiatives locales et
encourager mais malheureusement ces
initiatives locales ne perdurent pas
dans le temps parce que souvent elles
sont personnes dépendantes donc il y a
quelqu'un qui vient qui qui permet
d'initier et puis ça ne va pas au-delà
de quelques années et puis un manque de
formation des responsables locaux je
reprends l'exemple de la Guyane ou le
directeur de la CAF de la Guyane quand
il nous a transmis son son le plan
d'action pour les services aux familles
partout c'était écrit qu'il fallait
former former les gestionnaires de
d'associations formées qui peuvent eux
après monter de l'accueil du jeune
enfant monter des actions à la pas
tourné vers la parentalité etc
sur ces actions sur la parentalité et
d'accompagnement à la parentalité je
tiens à souligner que dans aux Antilles
particulièrement et puis à la Réunion
beaucoup d'actions sont menées sur le
rôle des pères puisqu'on a vu que les
pères étaient relativement absents des
familles ou en tout cas absents avec
notre regard de métropolitain ils le
sont pas toujours en fait mais
il notre regard fait penser qu'ils ne
sont pas là et que il y a beaucoup
d'actions qui sont mises en place à la
Réunion notamment avec l'Observatoire de
la parentalité sur
faire discuter les pères faire rentrer
les pères dans les familles parce que
les pères sont absents soit c'est
peut-être le modèle c'est peut-être la
volonté des pères mais c'est peut-être
aussi le modèle chez les maires de ne
pas avoir de père à côté d'elle d'avoir
de s'occuper des enfants et
effectivement ce qu'on a pu observer
lire
interviewer parce qu'on a on a aussi
mené des entretiens de sociologue sur
les différents territoires c'est que
enfin c'est culturel c'est très très
c'est un mode de faire famille qui ne
correspond pas à celui de la métropole
alors soit on décide la métropole décide
d'aligner sur sur sa manière de voir de
faire sa famille soit elle décide
d'accompagner accompagner passe quand
même par mettre l'accent sur le rôle des
pères et le lien perd enfant
qui évidemment dépend beaucoup dans les
outre-mer de la situation vis-à-vis de
l'emploi et des ressources du père dans
les jeunes générations il y a quand même
une volonté de s'investir dans les dans
la relation père-enfant
je continue je continue sur les
grossesses précoces donc on a eu
plusieurs questions sur les grossesses
précoces vous l'avez très bien expliqué
il y a des grossesses précoces qui sont
vous êtes issus d'une famille qui a subi
des violences vous voulez acquérir un
statut etc et et quelquefois c'est vu de
manière très
péjorative pour les jeunes filles
un accent qui doit être mis et qui peut
être mis là c'est que malgré ces
grossesses précoces il faut maintenir la
scolarisation de ces jeunes filles et
donc envisager des des lieux des lieux
d'accueil peut-être dans les collèges
dans les lycées pour pour leur permettre
de ne pas
il y en a la Réunion
il faut que ça se développe pour ne pas
que que ces jeunes filles se perdent
perdent leur scolarisation
par rapport alors vous demandiez madame
la rapportrice que pourquoi est-ce que
est-ce que c'est lié scolarisation plus
courtes accueille du jeune enfant moins
etc
est-ce que c'est lié je ne suis pas sûr
ma collègue vous répondra très très bien
sur l'accueil du jeune enfant
il y a des méfiances il y a une méfiance
quand même sur l'accueil du jeune enfant
il n'y a pas de d'informations sur
l'apport que peut avoir l'accueil du
jeune enfant et il y a une tradition
d'élever les enfants au sein des
familles de garder ses solidarités
intergénérationnelles et intra familial
assez forte et les jeunes filles certes
peut-être que la grossesse déclenche la
sortie du système scolaire mais elles
sont aussi extrêmement mobilisées par
leur propre mère leur tente pour les
autres enfants pour les frères pour les
sœurs pour pour
le reste de la famille
et sur ce lien entre grossesse et droit
du sol je moi je tenais et puis le
logement
adapté en fonction des territoires et
critères sociaux
j'ai eu la chance de bénéficier d'un
entretien avec Madame le Maire de
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni et on comprend
une chose c'est que les donc ça le rend
du marronnier étant sur la frontière
avec le Suriname il n'y a qu'un fleuve à
traverser et bien les femmes sur une à
Metz qui ont besoin il faut comprendre
en plus que ce fleuve ne fait que
séparer des des gens d'une
des mêmes familles et donc ces familles
sur ces femmes sur une hamès viennent
accoucher sur l'hôpital de Saint-Laurent
du Maroni parce que elles n'ont pas les
conditions pour accoucher correctement
de l'autre côté et un phénomène qui se
développe c'est qu'elle paye
elle paye des hommes français donc de la
famille etc de l'autre côté du fleuve
pour qu'il se déclare père de manière à
bénéficier du droit du sol et elle
repartent après avec les enfants et on a
il y a une madame le Maire m'a expliqué
qu'il y a une différence importante
entre le nombre de naissances et le
nombre d'enfants qu'on voit arriver à 3
ans à l'école
parce que ce sont les familles qui
repartent
et puis pour le logement elle
m'expliquait aussi et je trouvais que
l'adaptation du de cette politique du
logement en fonction de du territoire
était intéressante au lieu de construire
des logements sociaux surtout le
territoire de la Guyane est immense donc
il bénéficie de d'un terrain immense je
viendrai pas sur les complications de du
sol de à qui appartient ce sol et
comment ça se voilà qui est très
compliqué en Guyane mais elle nous
expliquait que plutôt que de construire
des les premiers logements sociaux qui
étaient ce que on imagine tous en
métropole des immeubles soit bas de
manière à mettre peu d'étages etc avec
des balcons ne correspond absolument pas
au mode de vie absolument pas au mode de
vie et donc finalement elle développe
une politique ou
elle elle fait acquérir en logements
social des terrains et elle fait une
aide à la construction pour que les
familles construisent la maison
leur maison elle-même parce que sinon on
leur construit des logements qui ne leur
convient pas et j'ai visité des
logements sociaux avec toute une ville
enfin vraiment toute une petite ville
qui s'est créée à Soula
et en fait les les familles partent de
ces logements sociaux ne s'intègrent pas
dans ses logements sociaux parce que on
leur a fait un appartement traditionnel
avec deux chambres une salle de bain une
grande pièce et une cuisine et c'est pas
comme ça que ces familles vivent et
effectivement cette adaptation est
nécessaire
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire aussi
[Musique]
alors oui pour pour désolé je reviens
aussi sur la Guyane qui est un
territoire en fait que je connais quand
même assez bien sûrement pas aussi bien
que vous madame
le dysfonctionnement des familles
d'accueil je suis pas sûr que le suicide
des jeunes Amérindiens qui est vraiment
une problématique très ancienne ne
s'explique que par cela même si
probablement
probablement ça n'aide pas
on n'a pas fait d'enquête sur les
familles d'accueil en elle-même pour ces
familles qui accueillent effectivement
tous ces jeunes qui ne bénéficient pas
d'un collège ou d'un lycée près de chez
eux et qui donc vont vers la presqu'île
de Cayenne ou
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'un collège ou d'un lycée
par contre on a on a on s'est entretenu
avec les responsables de l'azo donc de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance la Guyane est
un territoire où il y a beaucoup de
placements d'enfants
et que et les familles ne sont pas
formées les familles ne sont pas suivies
donc il n'y a aucun suivi des familles
d'accueil il n'y a aucune formation
quand vous accueillez un enfant de
l'Aide Sociale à l'enfant
issus de l'aide sociale à l'enfance vous
accueillez à un enfant qui a des
problèmes un enfant qui a des troubles
du comportement un enfant qui a un
manque d'affection et vous n'êtes
absolument pas formés pour accueillir
ces enfants vous n'êtes pas suivi et
vous n'êtes pas accompagné pendant le
temps de l'accueil
et
alors je vais maintenant revenir sur un
problème plus global une grande partie
de ces problèmes que l'on observe il n'y
a pas assez de construction scolaire à
Mayotte ou en Guyane
il n'y a pas assez de mode d'accueil du
jeune enfant etc c'est aussi un problème
d'endettement des communes d'endettement
du de la collectivités territoriales et
sur l'exemple de la Guyane il y a eu les
grands événements de 2017 il y a eu
énormément d'argent proposé pour la
construction d'écoles collèges et lycée
qui ne sont pas sortis de terre les
écoles si il y avait pas mal d'écoles
qui sont sortis mes collègues et lycées
qui sortent tout juste pour certains de
terre très très longtemps après et
pourquoi parce que il y a une vraie
difficulté pour les collectivités
territoriales de suivre et d'avoir des
compétences locales pour construire
c'est faire sortir de terre c'est c'est
constructions donc c'est pas que un
problème d'argent c'est aussi un
problème d'attractivité des territoires
et un problème de formation sur ces
territoires
écoutez merci beaucoup pour ces réponses
extrêmement précises il y a une petite
contrainte de salle qui ne concerne
absolument pas le président Stéphane
Artano à distance mais nous nous
risquons d'être mis dehors très
rapidement donc je vais je vais vous
demander éventuellement si on peut
contenir en 5 minutes maximum et s'il y
a des réponses complémentaires aux
questions qui est très précise de nos
collègues vous pourrez nous les adresser
comme l'étude complémentaire auquel à
laquelle faisait référence monsieur
Marie
ultérieurement puisque les travaux
démarrent aujourd'hui avec vous et donc
vous pourrez vous exprimer
ultérieurement peut-être de deux mots
juste par rapport à une réponse vous
madame qui ne vous aide pas exprimé et
puis ensuite vous répondrez par mail et
par retour avec des échanges aux
questions qui ont été posées pour
finalement rendre la salle à ceux qui
l'avaient réservé alors mais c'est
tellement passionnant que on vous écoute
moi je voudrais intervenir donc sur la
question très importante de l'accueil du
jeune enfant donc c'est accueil du jeune
enfant important à deux titres d'abord
parce que il permet la conciliation
entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle pour les parents de
jeunes enfants et en particulier pour
les maires de jeunes enfants et puis il
permet aussi une socialisation précoce
du jeune enfant
qui va l'aider ensuite entrer à l'école
maternelle
et on constate des différences alors
importantes en termes d'accueil du jeune
enfant entre la métropole et puis les
les dromes et entre les trois moments
d'ailleurs
donc en métropole le taux de couverture
par un mode d'accueil formel des jeunes
enfants de moins de 3 ans et de 60%
c'est sur 10
[Musique]
en Martinique ce taux de couverture et
de 55% donc pas très très éloigné mais
en Guadeloupe n'est que de 44% à la
réunion de 32% et en Guyane de 9% et à
Mayotte il est quasiment nul voilà
donc des différences très importantes
et par ailleurs on constate aussi que
alors qu'en métropole c'est l'accueil
chez les assistantes maternelles qui est
le premier mode d'accueil dans les
territoires d'outre-mer c'est l'accueil
collectif qui arrive en tête parce qu'il
y a peu d'offres d'accueil par des
assistantes maternelles donc ça c'est un
point
à la Réunion
le taux de couverture la part du taux de
couverture par les assistantes
maternelles c'est 23%
c'est plus cher
que pour les les parents qui ont sont en
dessous de trois SMIC oui c'est plus
cher que l'accueil en crèche et pareil
par ailleurs il y a la question aussi de
de la difficulté d'obtenir un agrément
de la part de la PMI pour les
assistantes maternelles en raison des
logements qui sont pas forcément adaptés
et donc c'est pour ça que
on préconise
un développement des maisons
d'assistante maternelle pour pour
essayer de
[Musique]
de régler ce problème voilà il y a aussi
la question de de des difficultés
financières des collectivités locales
qu'il est empêche ou les frênes dans
dans l'investissement dans les dans les
crèches et vous savez que les les caves
sol ne peuvent pas financer
l'investissement et la création de des
crèches et que les collectivités locales
doivent participer
plus de temps
je souligne effectivement que de mon
exposé tout à l'heure je peux parler de
la Réunion
mais pourquoi pourquoi je reviens
là-dessus c'est qu'effectivement on a
quand même une situation à la Réunion
qui est globalement structurellement
plus organisé une régulation plus
importante une structure des familles
qui n'est pas la même pas collègue sur
la monoparentalité
la moto parentalité vu à la Réunion a
une forte ressemblance avec la
monoparentalité telle qu'elle doit être
la métropole c'est des ruptures d'union
qui amènent un monoparentalité dans
lesquelles que nous avons fait il y a 10
ans
et on va la revoir ce que ça va nous
donner aujourd'hui il y a une structure
extrêmement différente entre ce qui se
passe aux Antilles par rapport ce qui se
passe à la Réunion donc ce qui veut dire
que la manière de prendre en compte la
position du père son implication ou sa
réimplication c'était ce que tu évoqué
n'est pas du tout la même là encore on a
un élément sur un sujet central sur
celui-là sur le rôle des pères on n'est
pas dans le même univers deuxièmement
globalement dans les dynamiques de
précarité ou de sortie de la précarité
si j'inscris la réunion d'une
perspective sur 20 ans on a une entre
guillemets des progrès qui ont été
accomplis à la Réunion beaucoup plus
importante qu'une dégradation relative
qu'il y a par rapport aux Antilles il y
a la quelque chose si vous voulez sur
les équilibres généraux qui font que les
modalités je vais dire un thème plus
large de régulation intra familiale
sociale les modes d'habiter le rôle des
espaces réunionnais la manière de les
occuper entre dans les Hauts c'est pas
être à cet endroit donc on a là quelque
chose qui crée la modalités de
fonctionnement qui mettent la réunion
dans une position intermédiaire et je
pense qu'il faudrait essayer de regarder
là-dessus mais ça ne veut pas dire que
le faisan ressortir on peut faire un
décalque sur ce qui se passe dans les
autres territoires ça c'est le deuxième
point et dernier point sur la question
de la de la monoparentalité qui
effectivement dans ce que j'ai dit
c'était principalement sur les Antilles
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important que j'ai confirmé par
l'histoire de la non reconnaissance par
les Pères et cette dimension là on ne
retrouve pas de trace de
l'accompagnement et donc il y a une
charge auprès des femmes avec
effectivement des processus si vous
voulez de
distribution différente des moyens des
femmes et ça indépendamment du taux de
natalité on est il y a que la baisse de
la natalité aux Antilles n'a pas
entraîné d'une certaine manière une
modification des rapports de parentalité
et ça c'est un peu aussi qu'il faudrait
qu'il faudrait souligner ce qui veut
dire que les modes d'accompagnement
alors je termine là-dessus sur
monoparentalité
natalité faite mes grosses précoces
fait que ça n'empêche pas des grossesses
précoces et les grossesses précoces et
là on se rej
oint sont souvent pour des jeunes qui
sont dans une situation de précarité
scolaire ou dans une famille de
précarité quelque chose qui lui donne
une identité elles deviennent femmes
avec une femme de reconnaissance il y a
un paradoxe c'est que dans le
comportement de ces jeunes femmes il y a
quelque chose de l'ordre de
l'identification comme étant existante
COS ne sont pas forcément subies à la
Réunion elles sont voulues et ça vaut
pareil pour l'absence de paix chez nous
l'inconscient collective a intégrer
malgré tout un modèle ou comme sur les
plantations les hommes venaient copuler
repartaient les femmes restées c'est
l'histoire aussi de l'esclavage et donc
il y a aussi quelque chose qui est lié à
cela
anthropologiquement le père est dehors
il est père mais il ne participe pas il
y a encore ce modèle induit et je pense
que vous avez dû rencontrer l'université
qui travaille
de la parentalité
mais alors écoutez vraiment moi je vous
remercie sincèrement pour la qualité de
de des informations que nous avait
livrées on a appuyé du doigt déjà l'état
des lieux les différences culturelles
les différentes de structurations de
famille les réponses qui sont
différentes l'état de la loi qui est
différent et la réponse à la fois au
niveau des prestations vous nous avez
aussi donné des pistes de réflexion je
remercie sincèrement mes collègues
rapporteurs et le président Artano que
je laisse conclure puisque j'ai démarré
voilà bonne à toi cher président cher
Stéphane et merci à vous Mesdames
Messieurs et on attend vos réponses par
mail merci merci de cette délicatesse
chère Annick chers présidente et merci à
mon collègue et aux intervenants et
intervenants pour la qualité de vos de
vos éléments dans la délégation des
délégations seront s'inspirées
évidemment pour mener nos travaux et
pour éviter que vous fassiez jeter de
cette salle de visioconférence
puisqu'elle est prise je vous souhaite
une belle journée à c'est je vous
remercie vraiment beaucoup de votre
disponibilité à très vite merci alors on
discute dans le couloir